et avec nous ce soir sophie prégent ans
qui est la présidente de l'union des
artistes pour soir madame près jean
françois fillion quel est votre
sentiment face aux annonces
d'aujourd'hui
puis positif qu'à l'en avant la demande
est là le point de presse de monsieur
lyonnais évidemment c'est sûr que en
termes de prévisibilité il va essayer de
se passer dans l'avenir à moyen ou long
terme mais au moins à court terme en
nous des réponses et je considère que le
7 février c'est c'est le début de la fin
le début d'une autre phase puis que
c'était nécessaire on va se servir de ça
comme étant le socle sur lequel on va
rebâtir à nouveau certains secteurs qui
ont été
extrêmement
[Musique]
affectés par la famille est l'un des
secteurs bien sûr affectés par la
pandémie vous avez vous nous avez fourni
des chiffres très intéressants puis je
vais tout de suite les montrer à l'écran
quand on voit l'évolution
des arts de la scène par exemple les
cachets et les droits de suite qui ont
été versés de 2019 et 2021 on voit que
sa chute et ça a coupé de moitié
pratiquement alors que dans la télé le
cinéma il ya eu une chute en 2020 mais
un rebond en 2021 donc ce sont vraiment
des artistes de la scène les spectacles
de théâtre qui sont particulièrement
affectées
effectivement parce qu'elle est en fait
tout ce qui n'a pas été tourné pendant
le début de la pandémie a probablement
été reporté un peu plus tard ce qui fait
qu on assiste à une bassine espèce de
croissance au fonctionnement on est à
peu près 130 % de ce que de ce qu'ils
étaient les chefs en 2010 neuf appareils
à moi pour moi en comparaison si pas du
tout le cas pour les arts de la scène
mise en lace cinq ans affirme issa a été
presque excusez l'expression me choque
dans on est descendu à
- 70 % d'incapacité
ça fait qu'on a remonté tranquillement
d'enfants ou était déjà mejia mélo
évidemment avec ce qu'on a novembre 20
28 où les gens meilleurs mouvements
évidemment voit rayé assister si vous
vouliez un crash dans le secteur des ans
de la scène parce qu'il faut comprendre
en fait c'est que ces 10 acteurs qui
sont les plus précaires n'y a pas de
droite souhaitent entre autres c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre même quand
l'audiovisuel était complètement fermée
il y avait quand même des rentrées
d'argent pour les wampas que il y avait
des diffusions qui est un kit est
offerte par gêne au genou un genoni ce
faisant vous le savez comme moi donc
avait quand même un minimum de droiture
qui étaient quittés en toi you ou aux
membres de l'union des artistes g olten
insectes en les embrassant car s'il
fermait c'est complètement fermé et donc
ça veut dire quoi quel est l'état de
santé financière des artistes
présentement au lido santé financière
juste pour vous donner un exemple
dans sa cadette le jour du jeu réside
dans les yeux ça représente en 2009 près
de 54% même pour 53 06 pour ça que notre
revenu il provenait du secteur occupé
entente de fusion cinéma ouais
maintenant on est à 67 %
alors la 5 c'est le contraire on est à
presque 18 % de revenus on est tombé à 8
pour ça c'est moins que la moitié
c'était donc donc font les
investissements les circonstances
exactement donc vivre les prestations
canadienne de la paie cellule la fameuse
pcu la pcr qui est maintenant la paix
cdcc le la mesure de confirmer
l'appréciation continue mais je vous le
savez probablement la mesure de
confinement ses 300 $ par semaine qui
est capable de vivre à lyon terme avec
un revenu de 300 demandes par semaine
avec une salle mais des fois de maisons
des voitures centre pépin alors on soit
qu'on veut bien que l'on a si on en aura
une maison un cordeau soit qu'on pige
dans nos avoirs c'est à dire nourrir à
l'union des artistes et si le phénomène
que l'on constate de plus en plus toutes
les semaines à l'union des artistes nous
signons des dérogations en fait pour que
les membres certain nombre qui en font
la demande plus à voir l'arrêt à ce qui
est terrible parce qu'en fait c'est leur
vieillesse wittstock exactement qui va
devoir payer tout ça c'est vraiment
c'est la pire chose pour un syndicat
c'est d'avoir à admettre en fait que
tous les efforts par exemple vous
comprendrez que sur la part producteurs
dans le milieu du cinéma qui la
télévision c'est 14% donc à chaque fois
qu'un artiste cesse en donnant par
exemple il y aura soit s'ajoutent 1 14%
donc 1,14 baraki et 10
par exemple les réal les assurances et
le fameux congés payés pour l'artiste
dont il est il et les ventiler il est
décliné ça fait donc 14 pour cent mètres
c'est forcément à coups de négociation
de chaque entente collective si on prend
qui on l'enlève puis on paie par mesure
d'urgence démonter des
leaders que l'on a qu'une et q2 instant
est ce qu'avec tous les reports puis
toutes les fermetures qui se sont
multipliées pilar bon réouverture est ce
qui est possible d'imaginer une fois
plus reprendre les activités sans avoir
l'arrière penser que ça peut encore
faire mais
pas pour moi je sais pas comment centre
les artistes me rends pas mes côtés
c'est la cinquième banque en a manqué ce
qui coule
c'est forcément pourrait toujours se
préparer pour une 6e place pour ça que
je sois bien évidemment pis j'ai espoir
que ce ne soit pas ce qui va se passer
leurs messages et de le considérer
pareil de gbl schwab puis on dirait que
le ressac épais à chaque fois que l'on
assiste à une vague on a toujours
l'impression que ça se termine ou qu'on
approche de la fin et ce n'est pas la
seule bonne nouvelle c'est que les gens
à cause des vaccins troisième dose de
ces noms sont de moins en moins affectés
par par la maladie n'est tout de même
vous le voyez comme ils pas on est très
très affecté union des artistes dont le
nombre
ok merci et bonne chance pour la suite
sophie prégent ans merci d'avoir été
avec nous c'est très clair et très
intéressant merci merci beaucoup
monsieur finir un roi pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit